the John wick series is a resounding
success with Keanu Reeves bringing the
retired assassin back for a third
feature-length rampage there's no better
time to break down how the actor
prepares to take on the physically
demanding role you might be surprised at
just how intensely he works to become
John wick while watching all the insane
stunts he pulls off in the John wick
films it's important to keep in mind
that Keanu Reeves is in his 50s yet he
makes those moves look effortless and as
often as they can get away with it yes
it's really him Reeves logged his first
screen credit in 1984 before many of his
modern fans were even born
since then the man has given us decades
of badass characters many of which
helped prepare him for his turn as John
wick understandably he's starting to
slow down a bit as he gets older but he
still puts everything he can into his
performances he mentioned in a profile
in Men's Journal I can't do stairs is
fast but if you say action I'll go to
prepare for playing John wick Reaves
goes through what he describes as a
three-month John wick boot camp to help
him get ready to take on the demanding
role the training regimen focuses on the
characters central concerns fighting
driving and guns lots of guns Reeves
talked about the routine in an interview
with page six revealing how he sharpens
his shooting skills before the cameras
roll as he described it basically just
take the gun home start walking around
practice spying rooms practice your
drawers and with John wick it's practice
your reloads transitions from weapon to
weapon footwork and then kind of coming
up with the John wick style Reeve said
he loves playing and training for the
role adding that he couldn't wait to
return for a third installment Reeve
said of wick as a character I love his
will his passion I love the depth of his
feeling I like his honor I like how he
fights for his life I like his sense of
humor
you work
yeah one defining characteristic of the
John wick films is how effortlessly
Keanu Reeves carries himself around
firearms he always seems totally in
control
utilizing the smallest amount of energy
possible in order to take out his foes
there isn't a lot of film trickery
involved in his technique it's mostly
just Keanu being really really good at
handling guns in order to prepare for
playing an expert assassin Reeves works
with shooting ace Taran Butler a world
champion in many shooting competitions
who served as a consultant for several
different television and film
productions and appeared on competitive
shooting shows like Top Shot and
impossible shots in his John wick
training Reeves has spent time with
Butler at Tarrant tactical innovations a
training ground for competitive shooters
if chapter 2 is anything to go by we can
expect the gunplay to get amped up even
more in John wick 3 John wick also
possesses some seriously impressive
driving skills which is something else
Keanu Reeves practices in his
preparation for the role because of the
degree of difficulty involved in some of
the set-pieces stunt driver Jeremy Frye
handles the most dangerous tasks like
pulling off the flying drift maneuver in
the second film however a big part of
Reeves is boot camp also includes
working with stuntmen to improve his own
driving skills for scenes behind the
wheel the fancy driving comes pretty
naturally to Reeves who's a bit of an
aficionado in the realm of luxury
vehicles he's been known to own a
Porsche and several impressive
motorcycles in past films he sat behind
the wheel of Ferraris Mustangs and some
impressive muscle cars of the 60s and
70s Reeves trainers claimed that his
driving significantly improved from the
first John wig to the second it seems
logical that he continued driving
circles around everyone in chapter 3 one
of the biggest problems with many modern
action films lies in the editing of
fight sequences whether it's to hide the
fact that actors can't really fight or
not many fight scenes today get edited
to the point where it's impossible to
tell what's happening but Reeves
impressive martial arts resume helps the
filmmakers he works with craft much more
impressive fight scenes by allowing them
to use long cuts and show techniques
that other movies can't Reeves trained
in multiple different disciplines to
perfect the fighting style John wick
uses jujitsu judo and practical
grappling techniques are all mixed in
with extensive gun practice to make
wicks abilities look effortless
the Kara Reeves takes to get the moves
right helps to save on money time and
editing decisions later on director
Chad's two house key spoke about the
production's approach in the lead up to
chapter 2 saying we're gonna do judo
jujitsu and tactical gun works so we can
hold all the shots
no cuts Keanu Reeves is workout routine
for John wick serves a dual purpose for
one it's tailor-made for wicks
no-nonsense explosive fighting style his
character needs ruthless efficiency not
bulging muscles so his workout is
grounded in that philosophy on the other
hand Reeves is in his 50s so his workout
is tailored more to strengthen his
joints in core muscle groups and have
them working in harmony Reeves his
trainer Patrick Murphy has said that the
John wick work out mostly utilizes
resistance bands in place of free
weights because they're easier on the
joints and helped the body learn more
control he spoke about the routine with
muscle and fitness saying that the focus
was on quote unilateral exercises like
ice skaters and single led pistol squat
hops which enhance proprioception the
body's ability to sense what all its
parts are doing and balance part of John
wicks massive success is due to its
amazingly choreographed and performed
action sequences they often read like
dance sequences and a big part of that
is Reeves is focus on nailing the moves
before the cameras ever roll check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]